Hi, my name is Beth and I'm a psychological well-being practitioner from Newcastle. I just wanted to say the biggest thank you to the contributors of the clinical psychologist collective book. I've enjoyed reading this so much and loved having an insight into the range of backgrounds and experiences. People have prior to applying for the doctorate and it's been really interesting seeing the potential barriers to the application as well and how I can try and work around this. I really started to doubt myself and whether I was good enough to apply for the client. clinical psychology doctorate, but this has really given me the confidence boost that I needed to give it a shot. So the biggest thank you ever. I've been thinking a lot about the phrase
嗨，我叫贝丝，是来自纽卡斯尔的一名心理健康从业者。我只想对《临床心理学家集体》这本书的撰稿人表示最诚挚的感谢。我非常喜欢读这本书，也很高兴能深入了解人们在申请博士学位之前所拥有的各种背景和经历。了解申请过程中潜在的障碍以及我如何尝试克服这些障碍，真的非常有趣。我曾经非常怀疑自己，不知道自己是否足够优秀去申请临床心理学博士，但这本书确实给了我所需要的信心，让我决定试一试。所以，真的非常感谢。我一直在思考“学校拒绝”这个词，
school refusal because if I'm honest, it's one of those terms that never quite sits right with me. Because when we say a child is refusing school, it sounds like willful defiance, like something intentional. But in my experience as a clinical psychologist, that's very rarely the case. In this episode, I'm delighted to be rejoined by Dr. Adam McCartney, a qualified educational and child psychologist. Together, we're thinking about what's often called emotional-based school avoidance EBSA or EBSNA. It's a fascinating insight into children, schools and parents. And stay tuned to learn what the most common age is for school refusal. The answer might just surprise you.
因为老实说，这是一个让我感觉不太舒服的术语。因为当我们说一个孩子“拒绝上学”时，听起来像是蓄意的反抗，好像是故意的。但在我作为临床心理学家的经验中，这种情况非常少见。在这一集中，我很高兴能再次邀请到合格的教育与儿童心理学家亚当·麦卡特尼博士。我们将一起探讨通常被称为“情绪性回避上学”（EBSA 或 EBSNA）的问题。这是一个关于儿童、学校和家长的深刻见解。请继续收听，了解“学校拒绝”最常见的年龄段。答案可能会让你大吃一惊。
Hi, welcome along to psychology and science. Actually, I am Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm delighted to reintroduce you to the wonderful Dr. Adam McCartney, who is a qualified education and child and community psychologist. Hello again, Adam. Hello, it's great to be back with you, Marianne. So nice to have you be back. And we've been speaking about actually,
嗨，欢迎来到《心理学与科学》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。我很高兴再次向大家介绍出色的亚当·麦卡特尼博士，他是一位合格的教育、儿童与社区心理学家。亚当，你好。你好，很高兴能再次和你在一起，玛丽安。很高兴你能回来。我们一直在谈论，
it'd be really helpful to think about an episode for what's called emotional-based school avoidance, sometimes called EBS. This seems to be something that really is a very emerging and pressing issue for so many schools and children and young people right now. Can you tell us what is EBSA? It's essentially where children feel they are unable to attend schools simply due to the level of stress, anxiety or emotional demand they feel from entering the education environment. I should stress as well, there's also another term. It's very similar, but slightly nuanced different. E.B.S. N.A. And the N.A stands for non-attendance. And the reason that exists is there's, the complexity of this topic is often met with judgment in one direction or the other. And N-A is trying to say that we're not looking at the child as being judged. So I think your viewers will appreciate that there's professionals out there. there who are always trying to remove the judgment factor on young people.
思考一期关于“情绪性回避上学”（有时称为 EBS）的节目会非常有帮助。这似乎是目前许多学校、儿童和年轻人面临的一个非常突出且紧迫的问题。你能告诉我们什么是 EBSA 吗？它本质上是指儿童仅仅因为进入教育环境所感受到的压力、焦虑或情感需求，而感到无法上学。我还想强调，还有另一个术语，它非常相似，但略有不同，即 EBSNA，其中的“NA”代表“非出勤”（non-attendance）。之所以存在这个术语，是因为这个话题的复杂性往往会招致各方的评判，而“NA”试图表达的是，我们并不是在评判孩子。所以我认为你的听众会理解，社会上有许多专业人士一直在努力消除对年轻人的评判因素。
Yeah, and thank you for introducing me to the term EBSNA, because I wasn't aware of that and I will start to refer to it as that in future because I think language matters, but also, you know, this child and young person, they're already having a really hard time, right? And so how we're talking about this issue, both internally as a school, as a parent, as an education provider, but also to the child, that really matters, doesn't it? Yeah, it does. Children, especially those in secondary school, are very attuned to feelings of judgment, feelings of shame, regardless of their developmental journey, it's part of growing up. Our teenage years are so heavily ingrained with forming our identities and how we relate to the education
是的，感谢你向我介绍 EBSNA 这个术语，因为我之前不知道，以后我会开始这样称呼它，因为我认为语言很重要。而且，你知道，这些孩子和年轻人已经过得很艰难了，对吧？所以我们如何谈论这个问题——无论是作为学校内部、家长、教育提供者，还是对孩子本人——这真的很重要，不是吗？是的，确实如此。孩子们，尤其是那些上中学的孩子，对评判感和羞耻感非常敏感，无论他们的成长历程如何，这是成长的一部分。我们的青少年时期深受身份认同形成的影响，而我们与教育
system is a huge part of that identity formation. And in the last 10 to 15 years, it has taken a drastic turn. And we are seeing increasing numbers of EBSNA on EBSA. But we're also seeing generally just students not being fulfilled by education anymore or not seeing the purpose of it in the same way that you or I might have seen in our days. You know, I remember my own. educational journey the idea of not sitting my GCSEs was like it just was unthinkable but now students and young people are much more aware of opportunities particularly online about how to make money that isn't necessarily linked to a sound and quality education so we need to do rethink this issue
系统的关系是这种身份形成的重要组成部分。在过去的 10 到 15 年里，情况发生了剧烈的转变。我们看到 EBSNA 或 EBSA 的数量在增加。但我们也普遍看到，学生们不再从教育中获得满足感，或者不像你我当年那样看待教育的目的。你知道，我记得我自己的教育历程，不参加普通中等教育证书（GCSE）考试是不可想象的。但现在，学生和年轻人对机会的了解要多得多，特别是在网上如何赚钱，这并不一定与扎实优质的教育挂钩。所以我们需要重新思考这个问题，
about what sort of demands we're placing on the young people today yeah I'm a big fan of Makita Oliver podcast with Lily Annan. I'm taking a while to actually listen to the old episode, so I'm still in the Lily era. And it's actually quite rare that neither one of them say that they've got really a GCSE between them, and they're in their early 40s. But like you said, that isn't super common for someone who's kind of in their 40s, because attendance was so kind of regimented and getting yourself to these exams, like come hell or high water, like you are going. And it isn't, it isn't so, uncommon these days, I agree.
关于我们今天对年轻人提出了什么样的要求。是的，我是莉莉·安南主持的《Makita Oliver》播客的忠实粉丝。我花了一些时间才听完旧的剧集，所以我还停留在“莉莉时代”。其实很少见的是，他们两人都说他们之间几乎没有 GCSE 证书，而且他们都已经 40 多岁了。但正如你所说，对于 40 多岁的人来说，这并不常见，因为当时的考勤非常严格，无论发生什么，你都必须参加这些考试。我同意，这在今天并不罕见。
Yeah, you know, previously the two most important skill sets were literacy and numeracy. But now we've got technologically literate skills and children can learn them passively or they can learn them actively, but
是的，你知道，以前最重要的两项技能是读写能力和计算能力。但现在我们有了技术素养，孩子们可以被动地学习，也可以主动地学习，但
they don't always need the education system to do that. How many young people have we seen learn coding on their own? I can't count the number of assessments out on. It's like, well, you can't string a sentence together, but he can code, you know, these types of skills. It's a different world these young people live in. And what's vital for us as not only adults, but professionals working with
他们并不总是需要教育系统来做到这一点。我们见过多少年轻人自学编程？我数不清有多少次评估了。就像是，好吧，他连一个完整的句子都写不出来，但他会编程，你知道，这些类型的技能。这些年轻人生活在一个不同的世界里。对于我们这些成年人，以及与他们一起工作的专业人士来说，至关重要的是，
them is that we've got to appreciate that their value systems and their priorities are going to be different to what we experienced. It's very difficult then as a parent who's potentially, you know, getting letters saying your child's attendance is below the levels of expectations. and, you know, I think, am I right in saying that parents can be fined for that and can even face prosecution when actually if you, you know, firmly believe that the education system is not a great fit for your child and yet you don't have the capacity to be able to home educate them yourselves, you really must be feeling in a, you know, caught between a rock and a hard place. You really must be. And I think the threshold for schools to start being,
我们必须认识到，他们的价值体系和优先事项将与我们所经历的不同。那么，作为一名家长，如果收到信件说你孩子的出勤率低于预期水平，这会非常困难。而且，你知道，我说得对吗？家长可能会因此被罚款，甚至面临起诉。但实际上，如果你坚定地认为教育系统并不适合你的孩子，而你又没有能力在家教育他们，你一定感到进退两难。你一定是的。我认为学校开始担心孩子出勤率的门槛大约是 93%。过去低至 82%，但我认为基准已经改变了。惩罚方面发生了什么呢？你刚才提到家长被罚款。不同的地方当局和不同的学校采取不同的方法。有些学校非常倾向于走那条路，而家长们也会通过他们拥有的任何法律渠道进行反击。但这会导致家庭和学校之间的不信任。法律框架不能是惩罚性的，必须是关系导向的。
worried about a child's attendance is something like 93% if it drops below that. It used to be as low as 82%, but I think the benchmarks have changed. And what has happened with the punitive side, you know, you just mentioned parents being fined. Different local authorities and different schools take a different approach to that. Some go very much down that route and parents, you know, equally will push back on that through whatever legal channels they have. But what that does is it causes distrust between the families and the schools. And the legal frameworks cannot be punitive. They must be relational.
它们必须以社区为基础。因为首先，那些家长会离开那所学校，转到其他地方，直到他们能建立起那种关系。但那种严苛的学校管理方式，并不利于对年轻人的长期投入。他们会建立负面联想，开始对整个系统产生怨恨，而这是可以避免的。我们必须与孩子们合作。而且，你知道，在我处理过的所有 EBSNA 案例中，当孩子处于不上学的边缘时，如果他们还有 70% 的出勤率，你
They must be community based. And because one, those parents will just leave that school and move on somewhere else until they can get that relationship. But being that draconian approach to school just does, it's not. not conducive the long-term investment in young people. They build up negative associations and they just start to resent the system generally and it's avoidable and we've got to work with the children. And, you know, all the cases I've worked with in terms of EBSNA, when the child is on the verge of not attending school, would say they've got still got in the 70% attendance rate, you can
实际上是可以挽救的。一旦他们全职在家，所需要投入的工作量就会呈指数级增长。这根本不划算，而且收益微乎其微。你知道，我记得有一个案例，我花了大约两年时间才让他们回学校待了一天。然后可悲的是，他们升入中学后又回到了原点。他们又开始不来了。这足以说明这些案例的敏感性。是的，确实如此。我记得在儿童与青少年心理健康服务（CAMHS）工作时也是这样。
actually salvage that. The second they are at home full time, the work that has to go in is exponentially higher. It's not cost effective at all. And the gains are marginal. You know, it took me, I remember one case, it took me like two years to get them back in the school for one day. And then sadly, they transitioned to secondary school and they were back to where they were. They stopped coming in again. It just shows you the sensitivity of the these cases. Yeah, it does. And I remember it well from CAMS, actually.
在过去，当出勤率达到一定门槛时，会自动转介到 CAMHS。我必须承认，我不确定现在是否还会发生这种情况，因为也许目前出勤率受到更广泛的影响。但随后必须真正与孩子、年轻人和老师合作，建立一个定制的系统，以最佳方式支持这个孩子或年轻人的出勤。这绝非易事。不，我觉得我在这次谈话中一直是个坏消息的传播者，
At a certain point, in days gone by, there would be an automatic referral to CAMS at a certain level of threshold of attendance. I have to confess, I'm not sure if that still happens because maybe attendance is impacted upon more globally currently, but then having to really work with the child, the young person and the teachers to kind of put in place a bespoke system really to optimally support this, child or young person's attendance. Not easy at all. No, and I feel like I'm the bare bad news at all times in this conversation
因为短期内情况似乎不会好转。你知道，对于那些关注学校或教育新闻的人来说，每天都有另一所学院说由于预算削减不得不裁员。这就是全世界的情况，学校可用的资源正在减少。我知道现任政府正在谈论改变这一点，我祈祷他们能做到。但资源确实在减少，这意味着老师们被期望承担更多的支持工作。助教们被期望做更多的教牧和反应性工作。
because it doesn't look like it's going to get any better in the short term. You know, for those who follow school or education-based news, every day there's another academy saying they're going to have to make redundancies due to budget cuts. And that's the world over the resources available to schools is diminishing. I know that the current government is talking about changing that, and I hope to God they can. But it is diminishing, which means that the teachers are expected to do more holding. The TAs or the teaching assistants are expected to do more pastoral, reactive work.
基本上每个人都被期望用更少的资源做更多的事情。当你面对一个有复杂或敏感情感需求的人时，需要耐心、支持，（你知道，只是为了长时间的陪伴）。而那个被期望这样做的成年人，认知负荷很高，承受着标准和实践的压力，校长还要求他们担任六七种不同的角色，这真的不是理想的情况，不是吗？不，真的不是。
And everybody essentially is expected to do more with less. And when you've got someone who's got a complex or sensitive emotional need that requires, patients being, holding for, you know, just for long periods of time. And then the adult expected they do that has a high cognitive load, is under pressure from standards and practices, it's got their head teacher asking to do six or seven different roles. It's not really ideal situation, is it? No, it really isn't.
真的不是。昨天晚饭时我和我最小的孩子聊天，他说：“哦，如果我不必去上学就好了，因为我可以一直待在这里。”我实际上对他说：“不过，当你上学时，我确实喜欢休息一下。我喜欢做你的妈妈，但我不喜欢一直担心：他还好吗？”他有偏头痛，所以我们必须一直让他保持水分。所以实际上他的出勤率并不理想，因为他会犯这些偏头痛。
It really isn't. And I was talking to my youngest child over dinner yesterday, and he was saying, oh, it'd be great if I didn't have to go to school, because I could just be here all the time. And I actually said to him, I kind of like the break when you're at school, though. I love being your mum, but I don't like having to constantly think, is he okay? And he has migraines. And so we have to keep him hydrated all the time. And so actually his attendance is not amazing because he gets these migraines.
我说：“我享受你不在那里的时光。”实际上，当我联系到这个想法时，如果他们在家时我试图经营诊所或在家工作，我的生理状态是不同的。我处于一种稍微不那么放松的状态，他们一直在我的脑海里。这很难。所以我认为任何有孩子难以去上学的家长，都有那种心理负担，即当他们可能并不真的希望孩子在那里时，
And I was like, I enjoy not having you there. And actually as I connect to that idea now, if I'm trying to operate a clinic or do my work from home when they're here, I'm just biologically different. I'm a slightly more like less relaxed state and they're on my mind. And it is hard. So I think any parent who has a child who's kind of struggling to get to school has got that mental load. of having their child there when actually they may not really want them there,
但为了孩子的幸福，他们允许孩子在那里，但这会影响他们完成工作或任务的能力，或者仅仅是获得一点安静的时间来支持他们自己的幸福，这非常重要。是的，这非常重要。
but they're allowing them to be there for their own child's well-being, but then it impacts on their ability to get their work or their tasks or just a little bit of quiet time where they can support their own well-being is so important. Yeah, it is so important.
我总是说老师是“第三位家长”，他们本质上不仅提供了你所说的这种喘息护理，而且他们还承担了家长被期望给予的情感负荷。他们以一种滋养的、有界限的方式与孩子相处，从而支持他们的社会发展，使他们成为一个快乐的、功能健全的成年人。那是理想状态。作为家长，我们必须记住的一件重要事情是，在现代，如果你认为自己被期望
I always say the teachers are the third parent, and they are essentially, not only the offering that respite care that you're talking about, But they are taking that emotional load that a parent is expected to give. And they are meeting that child in a nurturing, boundaryed way so that they can support the social development into a fully functioning adult who is happy. That's the ideal, Illinois. And the important thing we've got to remember as parents is that in the modern day, I forgive you for believing that you're expecting.
做所有事情，我原谅你的这种想法。但这不现实。而且过去也不是这样的。育儿一直是以社区为基础的。你身边总是有其他人。我记得和母亲们交谈，她们总是说，新妈妈首先想到的是“照顾好母亲”。她们不说“照顾好父亲”。在流行文化中，现在确实会提到了。但过去通常是“照顾好母亲”，因为家长的理智会自动支持孩子的理智。但如果你处于一个高需求、低资源的环境中，无论是在家里还是在学校，每个人都会受苦。每个人都会把问题归咎于孩子，因为那是声音最大的，可以这么说。但每个人的韧性都很低。孩子、老师、家长。本质上，我们必须回到
to do everything. But that's not, it's not realistic. And it's not how it used to be. Child raring was always community-based. You always had people around you. I remember talking to mothers and they always said, the first thing that comes up for a new mother is look after the mother. They don't say look after the father. They do now in terms of pop culture. But they used to be look after the mother because the sanity of the parents automatically supports the sanity of the child. But if you've got a high demand environment and low resources, whether it's in your home or at school, everybody suffers. Everybody then places it within child because it's the loudest voice, so to speak. But everybody's resilience is low. Child, teachers, parents. Essentially, we got to move back
一种以社区为基础的方式来对待教育、对待家庭生活，摆脱我们所做的那种孤立和自我牺牲的做法。大约一年前，我写了一篇关于“教育建立在善意之上”的文章。它建立在这样一个事实之上：老师们会利用放学后额外的那 20 分钟来处理一些行政事务，或者他们会在家里批改作业。实际上，这需要被纳入学校的一天中。
to a community-based way of approaching education, approaching home life, and getting out of the silo and martyrdom type stuff that we've done. I wrote a post about a year ago around education's built on goodwill. It's built on the fact that teachers will take that extra 20 minutes and after school to do some admin, or they will mark their books at home. Really, that needs to be built into the school day.
我们看看芬兰的系统。老师讲授课程的核心部分，然后每天下午花时间备课。他们身边有一个团队，能够胜任并执行他们的计划。有些学校可能会说他们做到了这一点，但据我了解，那里的系统非常稳健。非常有趣。在我们继续之前，是时候进行一个简短的“治疗室门后”时刻了，
We look at the, in Finland, the Finnish system. The teacher delivers the main core aspects of the curriculum and then spends the afternoon planning every single day. And they have a team around them who are competent and delivering their plans. And some schools might say they do this, but from what I understand, it's a very robust system over there. Very interesting. Before we continue, it's time for a quick behind the therapy room door moment,
由 Write-up 提供，这是我在自己的临床实践中使用的实践管理系统。在创伤和成瘾工作中，经常出现的一个问题是，人们感到足够安全，能够按照自己的节奏讲述自己的故事是多么重要。在治疗中，一个人经历的细节可能会随着时间的推移慢慢浮现，有时跨越多次会话。
brought to you by write-up, who are the practice management system I use in my own clinical practice. One thing that often comes up in trauma and addiction work is how important it is for people to feel safe enough to tell their story at their own pace. In therapy, the details of someone's experiences can emerge slowly over time, sometimes across many sessions.
但要使这项工作得以进行，人们实际上需要能够参加他们的会话。当一个人处于康复的脆弱阶段时，像清晰的预约提醒、简单的沟通和可靠的日程安排这样的小事，在帮助他们保持与工作的联系方面可以产生真正的不同。Write-up 受到超过 50,000 名临床医生的信赖。如果你想亲自尝试，可以使用描述中的链接访问最多五个用户的免费试用版。代码是 Marianne 30。现在回到节目。
But for that work to happen, people actually need to be able to get to their sessions. And when someone is at a vulnerable stage in their recovery, Small things like clear appointment reminders, easy communication and reliable scheduling can make a real difference in helping them stay connected to the work. Write-up is trusted by over 50,000 clinicians. If you'd like to try it yourself, you can access a free trial for up to five users using the link in the description. And the code Marianne 30. Now back to the show.
你能告诉我们，儿童或年轻人开始出现更多“情绪性回避上学”迹象的最常见年龄段是什么吗？我们自然会认为是在 GCSE 阶段，因为那是考试时间，对许多学生来说压力很大。但实际上是在关键阶段 3（Key Stage 3），也就是 7 年级到 9 年级。我们通常在 7 年级有一个宽限期，让学生能够适应新环境，习惯这种过渡，然后他们在情感上做出决定，看他们是否喜欢这种过渡。
Can you tell us what the most common age tends to be for children or young people starting to experience more signs of emotional-based school? non-attendance. We naturally think that it would be GCSEs because that is the test time, a lot of stress for a lot of students. But it's actually in Key Stage 3, and that's Year 7 through the year 9. We usually get a grace period in year 7 of students being able to tolerate a new environment, getting a bit used to the transition, and then they make a decision emotionally, whether they like that transition or not.
通常到 7 年级结束、8 年级开始时，我们就会开始看到这些数字的上升。有趣的是，EBSNA 也与排斥趋势相吻合。所以我们知道在关键阶段 3，排斥率迅速上升，特别是在过去 14 年里。我们认为这与学术需求的增加有关，也与从小学升入中学有关，中学的行为系统更加僵化，期望也更符合学术成就。这非常有道理。实际上，我自己的大孩子目前正在上 8 年级，你看着他们进入 7 年级，充满活力、热情和兴奋，
And usually by the end of year seven, beginning of year eight, we will start to see these rises. Interestingly, the EBSNA also matches trends in exclusion. So we know a key stage three, exclusions rise rapidly, particularly in the last 14 years. And we think that's got to do with the increase in academic demand, but also the moving from primary school to secondary school where behavior systems are much more rigid and expectations are much more in line with academic achievement. That makes so much sense. And actually having my own eldest child be in currently in year eight, you see them join year seven and have a lot of energy and enthusiasm and excitement for,
“我现在不止一个教室了，我有这么多老师可以合作。”然后我看到那种热情消退了，接着变成了现实生活。我想知道这是否与他们不像以前的小学老师那样感到被情感上所包容有关，小学通常只有一两位老师。是的，完全正确。我们刚才谈到了将老师视为“第三位家长”。在中学，与至少一两位老师建立这种关系非常重要。你在课堂之间穿梭。你一天可能有五节课。我自己的学校，我想我们一天有多达八位不同的老师。这些频繁的过渡既是福也是祸。问题是，如果你不喜欢你的老师，你只需要忍受 30 或 40 分钟。我实际上正在和朋友兼同事马特·罗布森（Matt Robson）开发一些培训，他经历了这一切，
you know, I've got more than one classroom now and I've got all these teachers to kind of work with. And then I saw it kind of dip off that enthusiasm and then it becomes real life. And I wonder if it's something about not feeling as emotionally held as they did by their previous primary school teachers, which often is just one or two teachers. Yeah, exactly. And we just spoke about viewing your teacher as the third parent. And it is having that relationship with at least one or two teachers at secondary school. You move between classes. You may have five classes in a day. My own school, I think we had up to eight different teachers in a day. And that can be a blessing and a curse those many transitions. The thing is if you don't like your teacher, you only have to suck them up for like 30 or 40 minutes. I'm actually developing some training with a friend and colleague Matt Robson, who went through this in his journey,
他并没有很好的教育经历，但正是与数学老师的关系让他度过了难关。他告诉我的故事是，在糟糕的一天后，当他离开教室时，数学老师把他叫回来问：“我们要怎么做？我们要怎么帮你度过难关？”这所做的是，一个成年人看到了这个孩子并说：“我在乎你。我要为你做点什么。我要和你站在一起。”这至关重要。这绝对至关重要。我记得即使在读 A-level 时，我天生就擅长生物学。这是我最喜欢的科目。在模拟考试中，我得了高 B。我对此还可以。我的老师只是说：“这对你来说不够好。”他想说的是，
whereby it, you know, he didn't have a great educational experience, but it was the relationship with his math teacher. got him through it. And, you know, the story he told me was as he was leaving the classroom after a bad day, the math teacher called him back and said, what are we going to do? How are we going to get you through this? And what that does is one adult seeing the child and saying, I care about you. I'm going to do something for you. I'm going to get alongside you. And that's vital. That is absolutely vital. I remember even doing A levels and I was quite, naturally good at biology. It was my favorite subject. And my mock exams, I got a high B. I was okay with that. My teacher just said, that's not good enough for you. And what he was saying was
“你有能力做得更好。”他只是在告诉我：“我相信你。”正是这种信念激励我继续学习并为此努力工作。因为我喜欢他，他也喜欢我，那种我之前提到的多巴胺，我就处于追求学习旅程的优化水平。我喜欢这个想法，这正是我们之前谈到的，关于在情感上收集（collecting）你正在合作的儿童和年轻人，如果你在学校工作。听起来你确实被情感上收集了，
you're capable of words. And he just telling me, I believe in you. And it's that belief that spurred me on to go and study and really work hard at it. And it was because I liked him. He liked me that then that dopamine, I was telling you about. I was in the optimal level to pursue the learning journey a bit further. I love that and it's the idea that we spoke about before, about emotionally collecting the children and young people that you're working with if you're working in a school and actually that sounds like you were emotionally collected,
你被放在心上，这让你不仅为了自己，也为了那个对你非常重要的关系而努力工作。我认为这是一个非常重要的考量。绝对是。我知道在当地，有一些教育出勤巴士，会把孩子们围起来，拖回学校。有时作为家长，你可能会认为
you were held in mind, which then made you want to work really hard, not just for yourself, but for that relationship that was really important to you. And that is a really important. important consideration, I think. Absolutely it is. I'm aware that locally there are kind of education, attendance, buses that come and round the children up and drag them back into school. And sometimes as a parent, you might think that's
你唯一能做的就是尝试帮助你的孩子上这辆车，或者你自己把他们塞进车里，送他们去学校。我认为这对孩子和家长来说都有很大的痛苦。如果家长正在与有 EBSNA 迹象或症状的孩子或年轻人挣扎，还有什么其他办法吗？是的，我的意思是，听到你谈论这些巴士，真是太令人痛苦和不安了。回到以社区为基础的关系，最重要的事情是什么？当你成为那个家长时，能够与学校建立某种关系至关重要。通常会有一个联系人，
the only thing you can do is to kind of try and facilitate getting your child on this bus or bundling them yourself into the car and getting them to school. There's a whole lot of distress, I think, for the child and the parent there. Is there anything else that a parent could, can do if they're struggling with a child or young person who's got signs or symptoms of EBSNA. Yeah, I mean, just hearing you talk about these buses, it's so distressing and upset and what's the most vital thing against coming back to community-based relationships? When you are that parent, it is vital that you can form some sort of relationship with the school. Quite often there'll be one person of voice of contact. And it's saying,
通常是特殊教育协调员（Senko）或教牧主管。他们在帮助你了解学校内部发生的事情方面非常有用。这是一个至关重要的关系。但如果我是那种情况下的家长，我会问关于“我的孩子喜欢哪位老师？”的问题。我的孩子如何利用这种关系来享受上学？当我与学校合作时，我经常谈论他们的教牧系统是什么样的？在我的脑海里，我想到的是中学。
usually it's the Senko or a pastoral lead. And they are really useful in terms of helping you understand what's going on inside the school. And that's a vital relationship to have. But if I was a parent in that situation, I would be asking questions about which teacher does my child like? And how can my child use that relationship to enjoy coming into school? And when I work with schools, I often talk about what? what does their pastoral system look like? And in my mind, I'm thinking about secondary schools.
他们倾向于将教牧系统设为：他们进入的房间，去见教牧主管。你会和他们交谈。然而，我觉得它需要更多地贯穿于整个学校环境。前几天我和一位校长进行了深入的讨论，我们都得出结论，核心学科负责人需要接受教牧培训。那就是你的英语和数学老师，因为你花在英语和数学老师身上的时间最多。所以如果你能每天从他们那里得到某种教牧支持，
They tend to have their pastoral systems as, you know, there's rooms that they go into and they go and meet the pastoral leading. You'll talk to them. However, I feel like it needs to be more threaded throughout the school environment. I had a long discussion with actually a head teacher the other day, and we both came to the conclusion that the core subject leads need to have pastoral training. That is your English and your maths because you spend the most time with your English and your math teacher. So if you can have some sort of pastoral support coming from them every
那就是滴灌式的。我们知道“少而频繁”效果更好。所以，回到家长能做什么，就是问：我的孩子喜欢数学老师吗？我的孩子喜欢英语老师吗？如果不喜欢，我们如何培养这种关系？这些类型的对话真的至关重要。不要觉得你会一夜之间扭转局面，这也不是像进去做一些 Elsa（情感素养支持助理）工作那样的离散干预，
single day, that's drip feeding. And we know little and often works better. So again, going back to what parents can do, it's asking, does my child like the math teacher? Does my child like the English teacher? If not, how do we nurture that relationship? And it's those types of conversations that are really vital. They don't feel like you're going to be, you won't get a turnaround overnight, and it's not some sort of discrete intervention like going in and doing some Elsa work,
情感素养工作。这更微妙，但更强大。好的，那么对于准小学生或中学生的家长来说，如果他们参加开放日，一个非常好的问题就是去查看并询问：“你们的教牧关怀是什么样的？”是的，那是一个非常好的问题。
emotional literacy work. This is much more, it's more nuanced, but it's much more powerful. Okay, so a really good question for a parent then of a prospective primary school student, or a secondary school student, if they're going to an open evening, would be to check out and to ask, what is your pastoral care like? Yeah, that is a really good question.
并且要有后续问题。它只是一个单一的团队吗？只是几个人吗？还是整个学校都有关系政策？如果学校非常开放和诚实，他们可能会与你分享那种关系政策。什么是“关系政策”？因为我以前从未在学校环境中听说过这个术语。
And have your follow-up questions. Is it just a single team? Is it just a couple of people? Or is there a relational policy throughout the entire school? If the school's really open and honest, they might share that relational policy with you. What would a relational policy look like? because I've never heard of that term before from a school setting.
它们并不常见。当我在地方当局工作时，我们有一个巨大的项目，非常棒。我喜欢它，我们帮助学校建立他们的关系政策。它本质上是移除行为政策，并将一切重新框定在积极的视角下，而不是因果和后果。例如，我支持的一所学校，当一个孩子通过挑战性行为升级时，而不是走惩罚路线，而是需要哪些成年人与他们站在一起。
They're not super common. When I was working in the LA, we had a huge project and it was fabulous. I loved it where we would help schools set up their relational policies. And it's essentially to remove the behaviour policy and reframe everything in the positive light rather than cause and consequences. So for example, one school that I supported with was when a chance, was escalating through the challenging behavior stuff rather than going down the punitive route. It was which adults then need to get alongside that.
例如，在第一阶段，可能是在午餐时间与他们的英语老师多待五分钟之类的。然后一旦达到某个门槛，每所学校会有不同的需求。所以我不想太具体。但一旦达到某个门槛，就会包括特殊教育协调员。在这所特定的学校，特殊教育协调员是高级领导团队的一员。所以这产生了巨大的影响。这意味着他们在系统内有一点影响力。然后是你的年级主任之类的人会与孩子站在一起。
So, for example, in the first instance, it might be spending five extra minutes with their English teacher at lunchtime or something like that. Then once it got to a certain threshold, each school will have a different set of needs. So I don't want to be too specific. But once I got to a certain threshold, it was including the Senko. And in this particular school, the Senco, the special needs coordinator, was on the senior leadership team. So that was a huge impact. It meant that they had a bit of clout within the system. And then it was, you know, your yearheads and things like that would get alongside the child.
所以这是关于何时引入更重的教牧支持手段并引入专业知识。好的。所以听起来 EBSNA 的关键方面是考虑将问题从孩子身上外化，这样孩子就不是问题所在，而是我们如何真正努力帮助支持这个孩子以最佳方式参与他们的教育，对于家长来说，不要把它想成是与学校的“我们对他们”。
So it was about when to introduce heavier means of pastoral support and bring in that expertise. Okay. So it almost sounds like the key aspect then for EBSNA, is to think about externalising the problem from the child, so that the child is not the problem, but how can we really strive to help support this child to optimally engage in their education, and for a parent, to not be thinking about it as us versus them with school.
实际上，我们都是团队的一部分。这让我想起了一点，如果父母分居然后有了继父母，我们如何才能支持每个人去爱、支持和关心这个孩子，而不引发任何战争，不让人们互相敌对。我们如何才能帮助这个孩子茁壮成长，而不觉得我们站在对立面，也不让孩子觉得他们是问题的中心，也许也要对他们的想法持开放态度？我喜欢考虑
That actually, we're all part of a team. It sort of reminds me a little bit of if parents separate and then becomes a step-parent, how can we just support everybody, everybody to love and support and care for this, for this child without starting any wars, without pitting people against each other. How can we just help this child to thrive and not feel like we're like on opposite sides and not having the child feel like they're at the centre of the problem and maybe being open to their ideas as well? And I love the idea of thinking about
你实际上与哪位员工有那种融洽的关系，我们可以将其作为干预的一部分来帮助你茁壮成长。是这样吗？我理解对了吗？绝对正确。而且我会说，每次都需要是同一位员工，因为这会导致倦怠。你需要将那种教牧支持在团队中轮换。
which staff member do you actually have that rapport with that we could then use, as part of the intervention to help you to thrive. Is that right? Have I understood all that right? Absolutely. And I would say it does need to be the same staff member each time because that leads to burnout. You need to move that pastoral support around the team.
你说得完全正确。这是为了避免那种“我们对他们”的心态。一旦你的孩子意识到你处于那种区域，他们就会知道他们可以逃避。他们需要知道，他们需要知道你积极看待教育，并且它是生活中必不可少的东西。如果孩子不相信你有这种看法，
And you're absolutely right. It is avoiding that sort of us versus them mentality. One, once your child clocks on that you are in that zone, they're going to know that they can get out the door. They need to be, they need to know that. that you view education positively, and that it is an essential thing to have in one's life. If a child doesn't believe that you have that,
那么你就在打一场硬仗。第二件事是，你必须记住你对挫折所感受到的情绪。你的孩子可能也感受到了同样强烈，甚至更强烈的情绪。正如你所说，远离那种“孩子内部”的指责，
then you're on an uphill battle. And the second thing is, you've got to keep in mind the emotions you're feeling about the frustration. Your child's probably also feeling just as intense, if not more intense. And like you said, moving away from that within child, blame, so to speak,
转向那种“关系心态”，即我需要和谁交谈，谁处于一个好的位置来减轻负担。这就是你作为家长的角色。这不是要成为你孩子的战士。根据我的经验，这通常不会带来好的结果。你可能会得到一份 EHCP（教育、健康和护理计划）或者你可能会得到学校以外的教育供给。但最终，如果你的最初目标是拥有一个主流的、梦想的、健康的旅程，那是不起作用的。
and moving towards that relationship mentality of who do I need to speak with, who is in a good place to lighten the load. And that is your role as a parent. It is not about being the warrior for your child. In my experience, it often doesn't lead to good outcomes. You might get an EHCP or you might get an education provision outside of the school. But ultimately, if your original goal was to have a mainstream, dream, healthy journey, that doesn't work.
关系永远是最好的关键。确实如此。当你说话时，我一直在想，好吧，作为家长我该怎么做？人们可能会说：“好吧，玛丽安是一位合格的临床心理学家。她是两个孩子的母亲。她有一个在上小学，一个在上中学。我敢打赌她一定非常亲密，非常协调。”
Its relationships are always the best key. They are. And as you were talking, I was just thinking, well, how do I, how do I do this as a parent? People might be like, well, Marianne's a qualified clinical psychologist. She's a mother of two. She's got one in primary, one in secondary. I bet she's like really attached and really attuned.
“我敢打赌她一定在做某种黄金标准的育儿。”我想说：“是的，事实并非如此。”但我确实做的是，我能够处于这样一个位置：大多数时候我会去学校接我最小的孩子，并带他去那里。所以我们有时间在事情发生前和一天结束时进行沟通。我确实尽量让那成为一个时间，你知道，我不看手机，我只是和他在一起，我们可以聊聊。但我知道这是许多职场父母根本没有的奢侈，所以我意识到了这一点。但我也，
And I bet she's like doing some gold standard parenting. And I was like, yeah, that's not really the. case, but what I do do, so I am able to be in a position where most of the time I will pick my youngest child up from school and take him there. So we've got that time where we can kind of check in about the day before it happens and the day at the end. And I really do try to make that a time where, you know, I'm not on my phone, where I'm just with him and we can kind of chat that through. But also, I know that's a luxury that many working parents don't have at all, so I'm aware of that. But also, I, I,
仍然觉得每天围坐在餐桌旁一起吃饭非常重要。在我们家，我们不允许任何人独自在房间里吃饭。这不是我们做的事情。至少晚餐不是。我丈夫偶尔会在周六午餐时间被发现躺在床上吃碗装的辣椒。我说：“那太恶心了。停下来。太可怕了。”
still find it really important to every day get around the dining table and eat together. We do not allow anyone to be eating in their rooms by themselves in our house. It's just not something we do. Not for dinner anyway. My husband can occasionally be found in bed eating bowls of chili on a Saturday lunchtime. And I'm like, that is gross. Like stop it. Horrible.
但作为一项规则，孩子们肯定不会在房间里吃饭，因为对我们来说，坐在一起谈论出现的任何问题非常重要。所以，你知道，学校昨天开始了一些事情，表面上看起来可能是一件很小的事情。他们有一个新的铃声，听起来非常不同。它是电子的。但他们也选择了同一天
But as a rule, certainly the kids don't tend to eat in their rooms because it's really important for us that we sit together and we talk about any issues that have come up. So, you know, the school had started something that might seemingly on the surface look like quite a small thing yesterday. They've got a new bell, and it sounds very different. It's electronic. But they also picked the same day
使用同一个铃声进行封锁演习。所以之后那天剩下的时间里，每次铃声响起，小学里的孩子们都以为他们要进入封锁状态，因为他们听得还不够多。但能够在回家的路上与我儿子谈论这件事，然后在晚餐时谈论它，真的帮助我调动起来，去感受他所经历的任何痛苦，而不是在当下试图解决它，只是进行那种对话和交流，但也
to do a lockdown process using that same bell. So then every time the bell went off for the rest of the day, the kids thought in primary, they were going down into lockdown because they haven't heard it enough. But being able to talk with my son about that on the way home and then also talk through it over dinner really helped me to tune in to any distress that he was having, not trying to fix it in the moment, just having that conversation and that to and fro, but also
模拟了一点我的一天。希望他们能培养出那种理解，即我们总是可以进行对话。而且，在协调时间方面，你知道，我并不是说每个孩子每天都和我有一对一的大量时间，他们没有。但我尽量留出至少五分钟，我知道这让我看起来很糟糕。但这是我能做的最低限度。
modelling a bit about my day as well. And that hopefully, I hope they're developing that understanding that we can always have conversation. And really, in terms of attuned time, you know, I'm not saying that each child gets loads of time one to one with me every day, they don't. But I try to ring fence at least five minutes, which I'm aware makes me look kind of terrible. But that's the minimum that I can do.
有时这是我做的唯一一件事。但在那五分钟里，作为校长，我不能。但在那五分钟里，你可能，我知道你在这里说话时没有意识到，但你所做的是你验证了你儿子的情绪。你没有解决它。但仅仅通过说“你的感受是有效的，但我会让你和它待在一起”，然后他就会想：“好吧，所以感觉这样是可以的。”然后，“好吧，它会过去的。”就像那句伟大的话，“这一切都会过去。”与情绪共处，我们在我们的行业中谈论很多，但与情绪共处非常重要，与不适感共处，并学习它不会结束你的世界。
Sometimes that's the only thing I do. But in that five minutes. that as an headside, I cannot be. But in that five minutes, you probably, I know you haven't realized that when you're speaking here, but what you have done is you validated your son's emotions. You haven't solved it. But just by saying what you're feeling is valid, but I'm going to let you sit with it. And then he kind of goes, okay, so this is okay to feel like this. And then, okay, it will pass. It's like that great phrase, this two shall pass. And sitting with emotions, We talk about a lot in our industry, but sitting with emotions are very important, sitting with the uncomfortableness and learning that it's not going to end your world.
这是你无法处理的事情。其中很大一部分是与能够包容你的人一起感受这些情绪。我不是在谈论那种包容，即“我会通过说所有正确的话让你感觉更好”。我会和你坐在这里，因为我喜欢你。这就是你对你儿子所做的。从迹象来看，它奏效了。是的。
It's something that you can't manage. A big chunk of that is sitting with those emotions with someone who can contain you. And I'm not talking about that containing as and I'm going to make you feel better by saying all the right words. I'm going to sit here with you because I like you. That's what you did with your son. It worked. by the signs of it. Yeah.
我必须说，我并不总是喜欢他们的行为，但我总是爱他们，我认为这也很重要，不是吗？即使我们对他们生气，我们仍然爱这个孩子，但我现在不太喜欢那种行为。但是的，我确实那样做了，我想。我相信你做到了。
I don't like their behaviour all the time, I have to say, but I always love them and I think that's important as well, isn't it? That even if we're cross with them, we still love the child, but I'm not a big fan of that behaviour right now. But yeah, I do do that, I think. I'm sure you do.
我相信你做到了。亚当，非常感谢你今天的时间。我很想从我们的听众那里知道他们有什么问题。你知道，我们可能可以再次聚在一起，讨论计划更多的剧集。所以如果有人对作为一名教育心理学家是什么感觉有任何迫切的问题，
I'm sure you do. Thank you so much for your time today, Adam. I would love to know from our audience what questions they've got. You know, we could potentially come back together and discuss planning more episodes as well. So if anyone has got any burning questions about what it's like to work as an ed psych,
我相信你一定会的。非常感谢你今天抽出时间，亚当。我很想知道我们的听众有什么问题。你知道，我们以后或许可以再聚在一起，讨论策划更多的节目。所以，如果有人对教育心理学家的工作有什么迫切想了解的问题，
any problems that you're coming up against with your child or working in a school or how we figure this stuff out as parents or my opinion as a clinpsych, let us know in the comments. We'd love it if you tagged us on social media too. You can tag us in your stories, you can tag us in your posts.
无论您在孩子身上遇到什么问题，还是在学校工作时遇到的困难，或者作为父母我们该如何解决这些问题，亦或是作为临床心理学家的我的观点，请在评论区告诉我们。如果您能在社交媒体上标记我们也将会不胜感激。您可以在快拍或帖子中标记我们。
Marianne Trent everywhere on socials. And Dr. Adam McCartney is on YouTube, on LinkedIn and on Instagram. There's also his brilliant podcast with his colleague and friend, Dr. Mike, which is called Between Two Sykes. Adam, thank you again so much for your time. I thought it was really important that we get together to think about putting an episode out before exams, before SATs, before GCSEs and A-Levels. So thank you so much for making time for us. Thank you for having me again.
Marianne Trent 在各大社交媒体上都有账号。Adam McCartney 博士在 YouTube、LinkedIn 和 Instagram 上也都有账号。他与同事兼好友 Mike 博士还有一个非常精彩的播客，名叫《Between Two Sykes》。Adam，再次非常感谢您抽出时间。我认为在我们进行考试、SAT、GCSE 和 A-Level 之前，聚在一起思考并发布一期节目是非常重要的。所以非常感谢您为我们腾出时间。谢谢您再次邀请我。
Thank you so much to my guest for today. And if you are liking the sound of Ed Syke, please do check out between two Sykes podcast. We really would love to know what you think to this episode. And if you've enjoyed this one and you haven't already caught the other one I did with Adam, where we looked at vignettes for what an educational psychologist actually does, I think you'll find that one fascinating too. I know I did.
非常感谢今天的嘉宾。如果您喜欢 Ed Syke 的风格，请务必收听《Between Two Sykes》播客。我们非常想知道您对这一期的看法。如果您喜欢这一期，但还没有听过我之前与 Adam 合作的那一期（我们探讨了教育心理学家具体工作内容的案例），我想您也会觉得那一期非常引人入胜。我知道我当时是这么觉得的。
And so many aspects of that have stayed with me. It was in fact my reflections after that episode that invited me to contact Adam and discuss chatting about EBSNA. You've got any ideas for future episodes, whether they're linked to education or another form of psychology and the way that we live our lives, I would love to hear from you. Please do feel free to pitch me your ideas for episodes via my social media where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If you like the idea of being a little bit of a fly on the wall into the inner thoughts,
那一期的许多方面都让我记忆犹新。事实上，正是那一期节目后的反思促使我联系 Adam，并讨论关于 EBSNA（基于焦虑的拒绝上学行为）的话题。如果您对未来的节目有任何想法，无论是与教育相关的，还是与心理学或其他生活方式相关的，我都非常乐意倾听。请随时通过我的社交媒体向我投稿，我在所有平台上都是 Dr. Marianne Trent。如果您想一窥内心深处的想法，
and workings of what it's like to be a qualified psychologist going about the world with all of the jobs and responsibilities that I do have. And you'd like to be able to access exclusive podcast episodes, which are called Inner Work. You absolutely can and it would be lovely to have you there. Inner Work is available on YouTube, on Captivate and Apple. And you can also get a three-day free trial on Apple if you want to check it out before you join too. If you're an aspiring psychologist, you might well find it helpful to dive into the aspiring psychologist membership, which you can join from just £30 a month with no minimum term. We have all sorts of experts there spanning areas of research, clinical practice, professional issues,
以及作为一名合格的心理学家，在承担我所拥有的所有工作和责任的同时，在世界上行走是什么样的体验。如果您想收听名为《Inner Work》的独家播客节目，您完全可以加入，能有您的加入将是我的荣幸。《Inner Work》在 YouTube、Captivate 和 Apple 上均可收听。如果您想在加入前先体验一下，Apple 上还提供三天免费试用。如果您是一位有抱负的心理学家，您可能会发现加入“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist Membership）很有帮助，每月仅需 30 英镑起，且没有最低期限要求。我们在那里汇集了各领域的专家，涵盖研究、临床实践、专业问题、
interview prep, application form, help, all of the good stuff you could possibly need in your psychology career. It often is more of a flavour for clinical psychology. But if you've got any questions about whether it might be a good, fit for you for your particular stage of your career or the journey that you're striving for, please do just slip into my DMs and we can chat that through. Always remember that the Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective are wonderful reads and get good reviews if you are working in the psychology career too. And maybe you're listening to this as a qualified psychologist, in which case I urge you
面试准备、申请表填写帮助，以及您在心理学职业生涯中可能需要的所有好东西。它通常更偏向于临床心理学。但如果您对它是否适合您目前的职业阶段或您所追求的道路有任何疑问，请随时私信我，我们可以详细聊聊。请永远记住，《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）和《有抱负的心理学家合集》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective）是非常棒的读物，如果您也在从事心理学职业，它们会获得很好的评价。也许您是以一名合格心理学家的身份在收听本节目，如果是这样，我强烈建议您
to come along and check out the next date for the psychology socials that I run with my friend and colleague, Dr. Claire Plumley. There's usually a link on my social media via Linktree, or we also have our own social account on Instagram called SciColoscials. And the updated details of the next available social are always up there. They're really good fun, they're in Kings Cross in London,
来参加我和我的朋友兼同事 Claire Plumley 博士共同举办的心理学社交聚会。我的社交媒体 Linktree 上通常会有链接，或者我们在 Instagram 上也有自己的社交账号，名为 SciColoscials。下一次社交聚会的最新详情总会在那里更新。聚会非常有趣，地点在伦敦的国王十字区，
and we have the most fun at them. It's a really nice chance to be with fellow HCPC psychologists, and the food is always pretty off the charts good too. You've got any questions about anything I do? I would love to hear from you. I'm Jo and I work as an assistant practitioner in a CAM service in Lancashire. I bought and read Marianne's book, The Clinical Psychologist Collective, to accompany me while completing the clinical psychology training application.
我们在那里玩得非常开心。这是一个与 HCPC 注册心理学家同行交流的绝佳机会，而且食物总是好得令人惊叹。如果您对我所做的任何事情有疑问，我很乐意听听您的想法。我是 Jo，我在兰开夏郡的一家 CAM 服务机构担任助理从业者。我购买并阅读了 Marianne 的书《临床心理学家合集》，以陪伴我完成临床心理学培训的申请。
It proved to be really good company. I found it sparked ideas of how to build experience and skills, but more than that, it offered the chance to get lost in people's stories. It provided a timely reminder not to get so caught up in an end goal and to value and enjoy each job we fulfil along the way, because the work we do now is important and matters to those we sit alongside, as well as ourselves. It also gave the reassurance that there are eclectic roots into clinical psychology, which is important for me as someone who's had a meandering journey and not a typical route to the profession. I wholeheartedly recommend the book for both personal and professional
事实证明，它确实是一个很好的伙伴。我发现它激发了我关于如何积累经验和技能的想法，但更重要的是，它提供了沉浸在他人故事中的机会。它及时提醒我不要太执着于最终目标，而要珍惜并享受我们一路走来的每一份工作，因为我们现在所做的工作很重要，对我们身边的人以及我们自己都有意义。它还让我确信，通往临床心理学的道路是多元的，这对于像我这样经历过曲折、并非走典型职业道路的人来说非常重要。我衷心推荐这本书，无论是出于个人还是职业
reasons. Be prepared to put evening tasks on hold for a while though, because once you've started reading, it's tough to put it down. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
原因。不过要做好准备，暂时搁置晚上的任务，因为一旦开始阅读，就很难放下了。目前这一期还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。